[Musique]
j'ai un gros défaut
j'adore traîner dehors à toutes les
heures mais j'ai une excuse
je suis un adepte du stargate sing star
easing c'est un joli mot anglais qui n'a
pas vraiment d'équivalent français qu'on
pourrait on pourrait traduire par
rêvassait aux étoiles je suis pas le
seul à le faire je pense que l'humanité
fait ça depuis des milliers d'années
moi mon truc c'est ses vastes champs
stellaires comme ceux que vous voyez sur
la photo où il ya des dizaines de
milliers des toiles on peut prendre
cette photo là depuis son jardin en
périphérie namuroise et autour de ces
dizaines de milliers des toiles
qu'embrasse le regard il y a tellement
de monde
deux mondes différents de planète c'est
vertigineux le ciel ne fait pas que
m'inspirait ilm aspirent également
c'est l'appel des étoiles je suis
convaincu que cet appel des étoiles tous
les stargazers le ressent tous ceux qui
sont passionnés du ciel le ressentent
je suis convaincu en fait que l'humanité
a une longue histoire d'amour avec le
siècle les plus anciennes
représentations du ciel date d'il ya
plusieurs milliers d'années
elle servait aux anciens à repérer les
astres qui rythmaient les saisons
lorsqu'il apparaissait dans le ciel
suivant la période de l'année
cela les aider à savoir quand ils
devaient se mais quand ils devaient
récolter et quand il devait célébrer à
la sous la lumière silencieuse des
étoiles au xviie siècle on a inventé
quelque chose de magnifique un outil
splendide le télescope le miroir que
vous voyez là derrière et le miroir d'un
télescope dit de newton parce que c'est
newton qui l'a inventé ce miroir c'est
le miroir de l'ancien observatoire de
namur il date de 1882 ce genre de miroir
vous permet de voir l'infini de l'autre
côté de ce miroir se trouve l'infini est
en fait le miroir va concentrer des
rayons lumineux pour vous faire
apparaître les astres lointains
grâce au télescope nous allons découvrir
de l'autre côté du miroir que l'univers
n'est pas seulement plus immense qu'on
imagine il est surtout plus immense que
nous ne pouvons imaginer pointer un
télescopes sur la lune a été déjà une
révolution il y à là haut des reliefs
des montagnes des cratères
tout un monde qui est à la fois
semblables à la terre mais aussi
tellement différent et surtout tellement
lointain se rendre sur la lune c'est
parcourir l'équivalent de 10 fois le
tour du monde
dans l'échelle des inconnus des
distances dit 2 août si floues la lune
c'est à des cahots schnock un peu plus
tard ou 18ème 19ème siècle les
télescopes vont nous permettre
d'explorer le système solaire de
découvrir notamment de nouvelles
planètes géantes gazeuses uranus et
neptune et de se rendre compte de la
taille caractéristiques du système
solaire neptune est éloigné de nous
d'environ 4 milliards de kilomètres
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut pour se
rendre sur neptune parcourir
l'équivalent de cent mille fois le tour
du monde
dans l'échelle des outils plus neptune
c'est juste avant mes gars ou schnock un
peu plus tard milieu du 19e siècle on
découvre la véritable nature des étoiles
elles sont comme le soleil immense et
tellement chaude qu'elles en sont
lumineuses elles sont surtout
extrêmement lointaine beaucoup plus
lointaine que prévu l'étoile la plus
proche de nous proxima centauri et dix
mille fois plus éloignée de nous que ne
l'est la planète neptune s'y rendre
c'est parcourir l'équivalent de 1
milliard de fois le tour du monde
proxima centauri c'est un giga ou
schnock alors que dire des autres belles
étoiles que l'on voit la nuit par
exemple les étoiles du baudrier dorion
comme à bil'in mais al mithaq et bien
ces étoiles elles sont plusieurs
centaines de fois plus éloignée que ne
l'est proxima centauri il faut parcourir
par exemple pour aller sur al mithaq
environ
soissons millaire deux fois le tour du
monde s'est agi gaou schnock le village
bon je vous laisse imaginer la scène
vous êtes trompés vous devez sortir
avant bételgeuse vous êtes arrivé à
gigas noc le village au lieu de giga ou
schnock bon c'est pas grave des enfants
vous inquiétez pas on a peut-être un
petit détour à faire on serait arrivé
dans trois millions d'années début du
20e siècle
le télescope permet de fixer l'échelle
de l'univers les nébuleuses spirale que
l'on connaissait au préalable sont
identifiés comme des objets identiques à
notre galaxie la voie lactée
en tout cas de ma nature elles
comprennent plusieurs centaines de
milliards des toiles et de matériaux
interstellaire que pour pouvoir en forme
et tout tout une sorte de génération
toute une série de génération l'objet
que vous voyez derrière moi la nébuleuse
d'andromède est grande comme six fois la
pleine lune sur le ciel ses immenses
comme objet et pourtant elle est
tellement éloignés que nous la voyons
telle qu'elle était il y a deux millions
d'années pour se rendre sur la galaxie
d'andromède
il faut parcourir l'équivalent de 500
mille milliards de fois le tour du monde
ça c'est pétaouchnok plage la définition
de pétaouchnok dans l'échelle des outils
plus c'est la porte de l'univers en
cédant à l'appel des étoiles en sait en
alimentant notre curiosité grâce au
miroir des télescopes
on a trouvé bien du vertige on a surtout
trouvé qu'il y avait tellement plus que
ce que nos yeux peuvent voir il ya une
vingtaine d'années 25 ans on a commencé
à détecter des planètes autour d'autres
étoiles
on les a trouvés dans des situations on
ne s'attendait pas du tout à les trouver
on a trouvé des géantes gazeuses qui
était très proche trop proche
probablement de leur étoile hôte
on a trouvé des planètes errante qui se
baladent dans la galaxie
on a trouvé des planètes autour de
cadavres des toiles qui ont donc survécu
à l'explosion de l'étoile
on a trouvé des systèmes planétaires
bien rangés autour des toiles laine que
l'on jugé auparavant inintéressante
ou presque
bientôt on va arriver à caractériser l
atmosphère de ces exoplanètes pour voir
jusqu'à quel point elle pourrait être
habitable pour nous et qui sait pourquoi
pas constituer un plan b
quand des fois que la planète ici
deviendrai inhabitable les agences de
tourisme exo planétaire que vous voyez
sur internet et bien le relève davantage
de l'assurance que de la fiction
peut-on espérer atteindre en jour ces
étoiles lointaines l'objet le plus
lointain que l'être humain étaient
capables de lancer c'est les deux sont
de voyageurs elles sont distantes
d'environ 18 milliards de kilomètres
distance qu'elles ont parcouru en a
environ 41 ans à ce rythme là si on
utilise la même technologie que pour
voyageurs il nous faut cent mille ans
pour aller sur proxima centauri pourtant
le voyage interstellaire n'est pas
interdit par les lois de la physique
très difficile mais pas interdite et
figurez-vous que l'objet le plus
plausible qui va nous aider peut-être un
jour aller visiter ces systèmes
stellaires et bien vous le connaissez
bien vous le contempler tous les matins
c'est un miroir
plus exactement une voile
réfléchissantes comme celle ci l'idée
est d'utiliser la pression des
radiations c'est à dire un flux de
lumière par exemple venant du soleil
pour propulser une voile à laquelle on a
accroché façon sauf pour aller explorer
l'espace lointain bien ça date des
débuts de l'ère spatiale cette idée le
problème c'est qu'en utilisant la
lumière du soleil on a déjà fait
plusieurs sondes qui utilisent ce
mécanisme on peut voguer aux alentours
du soleil ne peut pas aller très loin
parce que l'éclat du soleil décroît très
vite avec la distance dans les années 60
on a découvert le laser et avec le laser
a commencé à germer l'idée d'une
propulsion à énergie dirigée
c'est-à-dire d'externaliser la source
d'énergie des vaisseaux spatiaux de
propulser à distance en éclairant
éclairant avec beaucoup de puissance
dévoila réfléchissantes en leur cédant
de l'impulsion donc en les propulsant
dans l'espace
lointain à l'aide d'une source
complètement extérieur alors c'est une
idée qui peut paraître saugrenue mais
qui reprend pas mal d'aplomb à
l'international ces dernières années
depuis quelques années parce qu'elle est
jugée comme la plus plausible
elle est notamment le sujet d'un projet
d'une initiative soutenue par plusieurs
milliardaires dont marc zuckerberg des
scientifiques comme feu stephen hawking
des institutions tout ceci prestigieux
qu ils sont ambitieux le rider c'est
d'utiliser un gigantesque laser
construire un gigantesque laser qui sera
alimenté par énergie solaire et qui
servirait à propulser des microsecondes
de 1 g et de les accélérer jusqu'à une
vitesse de 20 % la vitesse de la lumière
avec ça on pourrait passer au large de
proxima centauri en vingt ans de voyage
ça fait un peu cher la partie de surf
mais c'est pas mal de mon côté je me
suis attaché
parmi les nombreux défis qui lie à
derrière cette idée extraordinaire le
parmi ses nombreux défis je me suis
attaché a modélisé la trajectoire des
voiles réfléchissantes et d'autres
fusées à radiation en utilisant les
outils de la relativité générale on peut
modéliser des allers simples et des
allers retours mieux on peut réduire la
durée du voyage pour le voyageur autant
que l'on veut en profitant d'un effet
appelé la dilatation du temps on peut
également calculer comment le ciel
apparaît déformait à un observateur qui
se déplace à une vitesse proche de celle
de la lumière et qui subit une
accélération as importante sous l'effet
de l'accélération et de la vitesse
extrême le ciel apparaît d'efforts mais
la couleur des étoiles apparaît changer
et si le voyageur veut pouvoir
s'orienter parmi les étoiles
il doit démêler ce sac de noeuds et
retrouver la position correcte des
étoiles pour ne pas se perdre à gio choc
le village
je peux aussi calculé grâce à ce modèle
le coût énergétique précis de mission à
voile réfléchissantes ou deux missions
infusé à utilisant des fusées radiations
pour envoyer des sondes de 1 g vers
proxima centauri il vous faut dépenser
l'équivalent énergétique de ce que
produit un réacteur nucléaire pendant
quelques heures
par contre pour envoyer une station
spatiale habitée comme la station
spatiale internationale
d'une masse de 100 tonnes il vous faut
dépenser l'équivalent en énergie de
plusieurs dizaines d'années de
production énergétique mondiale donc si
le voyage interstellaire n'est pas
interdit par les lois de la physique
iris il est surtout impayable il ne
risque pas non plus d'être démocratique
il va exiger de construire des choses
qui sont gigantesques qui vont nous
permettre de détourner si on veut
utiliser des vols habités il faudrait
détourné l'équivalent d'un dix millième
de milliardième de la puissance émise
par le soleil
un dix millième de milliardième vous me
direz c'est pas grand chose mais à
l'échelle du soleil c'est énorme c'est
plus pharaonique s'est littéralement
astronomiques alors quand on entend
souvent dire qu'une des solutions pour
nous sera probablement d'émigrés lorsque
la planète sera devenue inhabitable et
d'aller vers peut-être une de ces
exoplanètes qui sont habitables et bien
on néglige on vous gâche un peu le coup
extrême et le caractère non démocratique
de ce genre de voyage on vous cache
aussi qu' il faut pas oublier c'est
peut-être aussi que ça va nécessiter des
entreprises qui vont complètement
changer la face du système solaire
balafré notre étoile avec un énorme
panneau solaire ou plier toutes les
ressources en minerais du système
solaire à quoi ressemblera le monde de
demain
si certains d'entre nous est
complètement à l'appel des étoiles et
vont comme ça se refait sur leurs voiles
réfléchissantes à l'assaut des étoiles
les plus proches
quel monde laisserons-nous derrière est
ce que nous aurons le culot le cran de
nous retourner pour regarder une
dernière fois
tout ce que nous aurons abandonné ce que
nous n'aurons pas pu prendre avec nous
de regarder le reste cette partie
d'humanité que nous abandonnerons
derrière nous là bas de l'autre côté du
miroir
[Musique]
m